Vous ne pourriez vivre sans longue promenade par les prés et par les bois
Vous ne pourriez vivre sans chanter
Et quand un rythme de chanson est trop lent à votre gré
Vous le secouez en riant !
C'est bien ce qui s'est passé, n'est-ce pas, pour le temps du muguet ?
Il est revenu, le temps du muguet
Comme un vieil ami, retrouvé
Il est revenu, planer le long du quai
Jusqu'au banc où je t'attendais
Et j'ai vu refleurir l'éclat de ton sourire
Aujourd'hui, plus beau que jamais
Le temps du muguet
Ne dure jamais
Plus longtemps que le moi du mai
Quand tous ces bouquets, déjà seront fânés
Pour nous deux, rien n'aura changé
Aussi belle qu'avant, notre chanson d'amour
Chantera comme au premier jour
Il s'en est allé, le temps du muguet
Comme un vieil ami fatigué
Pour toute une année
Pour se faire oublier
En partant, il nous a laissés
Un peu de son printemps
Un peu de ses vingt ans
Pour s'aimer, pour s'aimer longtemps